I now think like everyone has a weapon
or everyone is gonna do something
harmful like I just now have this like
anxiety Kim Kardashian's personal
struggles continued on Sundays Keeping
Up with the Kardashians as the 36 year
old dealt with the aftermath of her
Paris robbery and her husband Kanye
West's looming breakdown don't scare me
please what's cooking on the episode
started with Kim at Kanye's st. Pablo
tour in LA her first time out since
being held at gunpoint I can feel the
energy of like people pulling out their
camera phones
god forbid she's smiling or if I'm you
know not smiling then it's like oh she's
so depressed I don't want that kind of
pressure right now
later the reality star addressed Kanye
needing a break in November the rapper
canceled 21 tour dates so it'll be okay
he just needs to take some time for
himself and just get back focused and I
think it's for the better
shortly after pulling the plug on his
tour Kanye was hospitalized the 39 year
old spent nine days at UCLA Medical
Center the episode ended on a
cliffhanger
Kim presumably hearing the news of
Kanye's hospitalization
you
[Music]